[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN POWERS: We're here to
talk today about a partnership
that we have with Google
called Accenture Managed
Services for GCP.
Joined here with my colleagues--
Firas Ghantous and
Matthew Abernathy.
We'll go through
the solution, how
it fits in the marketplace,
what's been the client
demand that we're seeing for
this with Cloud providers
and especially with
Google and GCP,
and why both ourselves
and Google are very
excited about this partnership
and the new ideas and things
that we can offer to
the enterprise that
wasn't necessarily available
as an option before for them.
So let's move right
into it, Matt.
Thanks.
MATTHEW ABERNATHY:
We've been working
for quite some time with
Enterprise customers
on their journey to Cloud.
And I wanted to talk about
how this kind of fits
into that because a
lot of the Enterprise
customers over the last
four to five years,
they've been spending
a lot of time
on the left-hand
side of this chart
actually working up their
strategy, their assessment,
the roadmap, and coming
up with a business case.
And many times in
that business case,
it includes what are we
going to migrate, when are we
going to migrate, what
are the priorities,
what are we moving to?
Are we moving these
applications to infrastructure
as a service, platform as a
service, software as a service?
When is part of
the business case,
which is always a big
block in the business case?
Could we potentially get out
of some of our data centers
and get rid of some
of those assets?
Wouldn't it be nice if
we could move everything
we're doing to more of
an OpEx flexible model
where we can be
off of what we're
doing from a CapEx perspective?
And those are usually big ticket
items in the business case.
And on the right-hand
side of the slide here,
now that we're actually
thinking about moving to Cloud
and doing things
in the Cloud, what
could we do and
leverage in the industry
on managing operations?
So a lot of things that
Accenture has done with clients
is on the slide.
These are the services
that we provide to clients.
And as part of that,
Accenture, we've
been on a journey as
a company ourselves
to leverage Cloud technologies
for our own IT uses
within our own corporation.
We're 450,000 person,
global company.
As you can imagine, quite a bit
of IT to run our own business.
And so we've been on
journey the last seven years
of moving the
majority of everything
Accenture does from an IT
perspective to the Cloud.
And I believe we're over 95% in
the Cloud today as a company.
And by the way, that was
written in our strategy
and our business case
over seven years ago.
And all of the tools
and things that we've
built around strategy, business
case work for our own company
and migration tools
and migration factory,
we took all those and have
turned those into things
that we bring to customers
as part of services.
And what we're here
to talk about today
is the one down on
the far right there.
We actually had
built through time
what we call Accenture's
Application Optimize Private
Cloud.
I know it's a mouthful, but
it's Accenture's private cloud.
And we offer and sell
that to customers,
so they could actually run
private Cloud infrastructure,
run and managed by
Accenture, and we can take
on their Enterprise workloads.
And so what we did with
Google in our partnership
was base our
solution with Google
on this technology
from Accenture
that we'll go into today.
Let's move to the next slide.
So today, we've taken our
private Cloud technology.
It is available in US East with
Google in the same data center
GCP is.
We have plans to expand and
offer the same private Cloud
capability adjacent to Google
Cloud Platform in London
and Frankfurt and
other locations as we
go through time.
The idea is many of the reasons
that the Enterprise customers
can't get out of those
data centers is they
have a lot of large applications
and workloads, which
will take them a significant
amount of time to refactor
onto Cloud technologies,
things like Oracle Application,
Oracle Suites,
large SAP landscapes
with monster HANA databases.
Those are really
big kind of items
that, number one, harder and
longer to refactor the Cloud--
not necessarily
you can't do it--
and number two, for
maybe performance
or regulatory or compliance
reasons, it's easier for them
to leave it in the data
center for a while.
So this option allows them to
take those Oracle workloads
and have them sitting in the
data center less than one
millisecond away from GCP
and in a private Cloud that
will run that for them.
And we can run Oracle
workloads and manage
that for the clients.
We can run ASAP landscapes and
manage that for the clients
up to the largest in the
world on this platform.
And we can run bare-metal
for the clients as well.
So if they have a
particular application,
we're starting to
run into things
that are 20 to 30 years
old the Enterprise
still has where they just
want a bare-metal server.
And they're going to
run it on this platform,
but they want it next
to the Cloud provider
because they're moving the
majority of their applications
to the Cloud provider.
Next slide.
So I don't know if
you've heard this term.
We've been using this at
Accenture quite a bit.
We talk about hybrid Cloud,
which this certainly is.
But this is taking the hybrid
Cloud or private Cloud model
to the next level.
And it's Cloud
adjacency, meaning
we're taking the private
Cloud technology,
sticking it less than 1
millisecond away from GCP
from a networking perspective,
and offering clients
the ability to
run any Enterprise
workload that they have
directly on this private Cloud.
From an Oracle perspective, it
actually is very advantageous
for the customer with respect
to the Oracle licenses
because Oracle, as
many of you know,
if you move your Oracle Licenses
to other Cloud providers--
some of the other ones out there
I won't mention that compete
against GCP--
Oracle will double the license
costs to run it in the Cloud.
When you run it in this private
Cloud at the end of the day,
it's managed colo,
which customers have
been doing for years and years.
So their licenses are
completely transferable to run
in this model without getting
hit with double license
charges, which makes
this very financially
attractive because not
only do they get out
of the model of running it
in their own data centers,
but those licenses they can
still use on this platform.
So we get back over to
the results side of this--
managed, purpose-built,
very fast performance
for these applications.
In many cases, for
the clients who
are running on old
hardware stacks,
they're moving to this, which is
the latest, greatest technology
from our partners in
this platform from HPE,
[? Eastern ?] Networking,
Nimble Storage.
We use VMware as our base
in this infrastructure,
including a huge amount
of management and security
that Accenture has built over
the years for Accenture's use
for our own private
Cloud and private Clouds
that we run all around
the world for clients
are built into this
platform, so very secure.
And it also moves into a
model for the customers that's
much more flexible.
So they're paying for use
of this infrastructure
on a monthly basis.
It will show up
in their GCP bill
as a monthly charge for
use of these services.
Support will come from
Google, level 1 support,
and Accenture will be level 2
and level 3 for this offering
in the marketplace.
So as you can see,
we're trying to make
this a more integrated
experience for Google clients
to quickly leverage and
be able to get access
to this infrastructure for
their Enterprise applications
like Oracle, SAP,
VMware, or anything else
because it's very,
very flexible.
So with that, let me
turn it over to Firas
who's going to dive down into
the architecture, how this
works, and then show you a
demo live of the infrastructure
of us on GCP communicating
with an Oracle database
on the platform.
FIRAS GHANTOUS: Thanks, Dan.
Hi, everybody.
So I'm Firas Ghantous.
I'm part of Accenture's Google
Business Group, the AGBG,
and I manage an offering
that's all around getting
your data into GCP.
This is one part
of that offering.
So as Dan said, this is about
getting those workloads that
have data that you want
to get into the GCP
to do analytics or
AI or ML against,
but you have some block
to running it in GCP,
be that regulatory,
be it performance,
be to commercial issue.
We're offering our AOPC in
those same data centers as GCP,
so you can get that data there.
As Dan said, we're connected
within 1 millisecond.
We manage all the networking.
There's no data egress
costs between the region
that we deploy this
and GCP and AOPC.
So obviously, if
you were to take it
from one region to another, you
pay the typical networking cost
of GCP.
But right now, for example, in
US East 4 where we're deployed,
you can run as many
workloads in US East
4 connected to anything
running in here,
and there's no data
egress costs at all.
So a little bit about the
AOPC at a functional level.
What we have here are--
it's comprised of
three distinct areas.
The middle area is
the management RACKs.
Everything has
redundancy in there,
so there's two management RACKs
that have all the software that
manages the environment.
So that's your
provisioning software,
your monitoring software, your
network security software.
Everything in there runs
in those management RACKs.
On the right side, we
have the virtual side.
So this is just a
large VMware farm.
You could potentially
run Anthos.
We all heard about
that this week.
You could run Anthos on there.
You can run individual
VMware machines.
For example, if you've got
an older application that's
very chatty with
the Oracle database
and even 1 millisecond
degrades the performance,
you can then run
those in a cluster
or in an individual VMware
guest on that virtual side.
On the left side is the
physical bare-metal.
So that's where we deploy
the high-performance, compute
infrastructure to support
things like 20-terabyte SAP HANA
databases or your
Oracle databases.
And we'll get into the
Oracle standard landscapes
in a little bit.
The reason that
we're putting Oracle
on this side, as Dan alluded
to, is the Oracle licensing
restrictions.
If you take a database and
you run it in a VMware farm,
you're going to have to
license all the physical cores,
whether or not those are
available to your guests.
So we're taking Oracle and
deploying it on bare-metal
so that you have a
license cost that's
[? commensurate ?] of
the cores that you have.
So we have a couple
of options there.
If you need 50
cores or 40 cores,
whatever, you get
a physical box.
And then there'll
be some smaller
ones that use OVM to
virtualize, so you
can get two or four cores.
We also have the ability to
configure all of our databases
within Oracle Grid and
Oracle RAC configuration.
So you can have two nodes,
three nodes, four nodes.
Again, that's there for
HA, as well as performance.
So that's a little bit of
the functional overview.
Can we go to next slide please?
We alluded this earlier
around the licensing.
This is list price, so
just keep that in mind.
But we wanted to make sure
that we showed a comparison.
If you've got an Oracle
database that's running on-prem
and you're considering
moving it to the Cloud,
if you were to move to one
of the other public Cloud
providers, that 12 core
license that you have on-prem
would double in price.
Because ours is
bare-metal and/or
we're using Oracle Technology
for virtualization,
it's the same EULA cost.
That does not change.
Our model is a BYOL, so you
do maintain that leadership
with Oracle for support
and buy the license.
But you're able to
transfer that license over
to this environment and
license your database.
We'll have time
for questions later
if anybody's got questions.
Can we move on?
So then, as far as how we
deployed in US East 4 right
now, as I said earlier, we've
got two management RACKs
for redundancy to ensure
that we have availability.
We use all HPE hardware
in our environment,
so we've got Nimble Storage.
Everything comes with
solid state storage,
both on the physical side,
as well as the virtual side.
Obviously, there's
virtualization
for that storage, but its
still underlying hardware
is HPE Nimble.
And then, we've got the
HPE switches and network
here at the top of
RACK that we all
manage to segregate network
between the different workflows
that are running
on the environment.
Can we move on?
Can we go on?
So then, we've
worked with Google
to come up with a couple
of different use cases.
One use cases is
an SAP landscape,
another one there's
Oracle, and the other one
is individual VMware guests.
Because this is our own hardware
and it's physical bare-metal,
we're able to host any workload
that can run on an x86 chipset
because we're
underlying HPE hardware.
But we have defined and will
be available in marketplace
by next week specific use
cases just as guidance
for customers that are
interested in this solution.
So the first one we'll
talk about a little bit
is SAP environments.
So what we're
showing here is kind
of four landscapes that cover
production, test, QA, and DR--
four SAP landscapes
that we can deploy.
Obviously, the
small and the medium
are things that you can
run in GCP right now.
You're certified up
to 4 terabyte HANA.
I think 6 terabytes is coming
this summer and 8 in the fall.
What's interesting
is when you get
to the large and the
extra large where
we can scale up to 20
terabyte HANA databases
and scale out to 64 terabytes
using HPE Superdome.
So this enables the
largest enterprises
to run the biggest
SAP environments
on bare-metal connected to GCP.
In certain instances,
you can even
run part of your SAP landscape
in GCP connecting to that HANA
or maybe underlying
Oracle database that
manages that data in SAP.
Depending on those applications
and how they perform,
we see customers doing that.
So that's an interesting option.
And again, the idea is we're
getting your data into GCP
so that you can leverage all
the great things are on data
analytics that GCP enables.
Can we move on?
So around our Oracle, our
first set of Oracle offerings
are on physical environments.
So it goes from 12 core,
24 core, and 56 core.
Again, as I said
earlier, all of these
are available in grid
configurations, as well as
RACK configurations.
They're all backed up.
I'll talk about it a
little bit later when we're
doing the provisioning script.
What happens is
when you order this,
you tell us how
many nodes you need.
You'll give us some information.
And then we'll
automatically provision them
and give you access to them.
And we'll show that in the demo.
These are the three
t-shirt sizes for Oracle
that we're offering standard
through marketplace.
And then, we also have
smaller virtual Oracle servers
starting at 2 cores
and go up to 16 cores.
This uses OVM, again, so that
you can honor that EULA license
for the core cost.
And the operating system for
all of the Oracle environments
are either Red Hat Enterprise
Linux or Oracle Enterprise
Linux.
Those are the two options
for operating systems.
Again, because it's--
I keep saying again, excuse
me-- because it's bare-metal,
you do have an option if you
have an older version of Oracle
that's maybe not supported--
we talked to a customer that
had Oracle Version 9 or you want
a different operating system--
we are able to give
you a bare-metal box.
And then you will configure
that box to meet your needs.
At that point, some of our
support standard services
are on backup and monitoring no
longer in effect because it's
a non-standard deployment.
But it still enables you
to get some of those older
environments and
workloads running into GCP
and connect there.
You still get all
the network benefits.
the connectivity.
It's just that some of
our management services
will scale back a little bit
because of diversion control.
And then finally, if you
have individual VM guests.
Again, this is really
meant for if you've
got an app or a web tier
connected to that database
and it's just an older
configuration so that you still
have performance
degradation or you're not
ready to hop on a GCE and you've
got a couple of VMware loads
you want to run, we
can host those here.
So now we're going to go
through our demonstration.
So I'll just talk you through
it while Matt lines it up.
So the first thing is how
you order in marketplace.
So if you go to marketplace.
It's a tab.
If you go to marketplace,
you'll search for Accenture,
and you'll see the three
tiles that we have on there.
And one of them is Oracle,
one's SAP, and one's VM Guest.
So then you-- sorry.
There you go.
Yep.
So when you select that, you'll
see that it's informational
where you click Learn More.
That's our initial
integration in the marketplace
due to some limitations
about the ability
to add more subscriptions.
So let's say you bought
one Oracle server
and you came back
three months later
and you needed another one, we
manage the order through a site
that Accenture sets up.
So as we progress
our integration,
you'll start to see this
actually in Google console.
It'll be in a left-hand
menu eventually.
But right now, this is
the process for ordering.
So if you click on
Oracle, and then you
click on Learn More, which is
that link right down there,
it'll take you to a screen.
In this screen, you'll
start to enter your customer
information.
So this is the
contact information
we need so that we
reach out to you
to know who to send
an IP address to
and things like that.
Once you enter that information,
you'll click Proceed to Design.
And this is where we capture
the technical information.
That didn't work, did it?
Oh, contact phone.
You got to put a
phone number in.
So one of the things that
we'll capture from you
is network information.
So the way this works is
we've got a GCP project
that Accenture administers
that's setup in GCP,
and we've got one week
to create VPC networks
for each of the customers
running in this environment.
What we do is we need
to capture network
information from
yourselves so that we
can peer our VPC networks.
That enables us to segregate
all network traffic
to ensure that your
workloads don't ever conflict
with anybody else's workloads.
We also want to capture
in the network information
your IP range that you want us
to allocate to these servers,
to your bare-metal
physical servers.
We're not going to
guess what the IP is.
We don't want a conflict
with an existing IP range
that you have.
So in that information--
do you want
to click on Enter Network Info?
That button at the top.
That'll come up here a second.
You'll see where you'll
enter the IP range, your VPC
information, things like that.
You can hit back or do that.
Once you've submitted your
order, somebody from Accenture
will reach out to you and
confirm that information
and then actually
start the VPC peer.
As you know, you've got to do
a VPC peer from both projects.
So we'll connect to your VPC.
You'll connect to yours.
We'll ensure that that peering
worked and all the routes have
transferred, and we
confirm that that works.
And on the other screen--
can you hit back on
the ordering screen?
Thanks.
Just down at the bottom.
Hit back.
Thanks.
So this is where,
in this instance,
we're gathering information
on the Oracle environment.
So you'll tell us what the
server size that you want
through what's available,
the number of nodes,
do you need them in
a cluster or not,
all that information, how much
storage do you want, et cetera.
So we gather all
that information,
and then if you were to hit
Next, which we won't show,
and you'll hit Submit Order,
then that's completed.
It comes to Accenture.
And as I said, somebody reaches
out to the contact information.
This is manual right now only
because of the VPC peering
that needs to happen.
Once that's done, all
of the provisioning
is automated, which
we're going to show next.
When we get all
your information--
that's that QuickTime video--
we start to provision
the Oracle database.
And that's all run through
what we call DDI, which
is Data-Driven Infrastructure.
This is an Accenture--
it's a separate window.
You want to run the DDI video?
MATTHEW ABERNATHY: Yeah.
It's embedded in a slide--
FIRAS GHANTOUS: No.
It is not.
It's QuickTime.
MATTHEW ABERNATHY: Thank you.
FIRAS GHANTOUS: So
Accenture, as Dan said,
we've had this private
Cloud out in the marketplace
for a long time.
And over the time, we've
developed our own orchestration
and provisioning.
We leverage, of course,
Jenkins and VRO from VMware
and all these things.
But what we've created
is a patented tool set
that allows us to
develop what we
call application fingerprints
for complex applications.
So if you saw earlier, I talked
about the SAP landscapes.
We showed those landscapes.
So we can actually automate
the build out of a full end
to end SAP test landscape
that includes all
of your witness servers,
your database servers,
the application servers,
everything with the data load
so that it's ready to go,
all in one fell swoop.
So what we're
showing here are all
the different Jenkins
scripts and all the things
that interact into building out
on the bare-metal, the Oracle
server that we're going to
connect to in the next slide.
This is all based on,
like I said, our thing
what's called DDI.
It includes all your
operational software.
So all the databases,
everything that we deploy,
standard backups is incremental
nightly, and every week it's
a full backup.
And then, we retain
that for 30 days.
Part of the ordering
process is you'll
let us know if that
meets your needs
or you need longer
retention, less retention.
Maybe you don't want us
to back it up at all.
You're going to do it all
yourself-- all of that stuff.
So all of those things
feed into these scripts,
and then we provision it the
way that you've ordered it.
You want to hit dismiss here?
MATTHEW ABERNATHY: Which one?
FIRAS GHANTOUS: Dismiss.
No, no.
Close that.
Sorry.
Hey, I should be here
right now by the way.
I think that's what that says.
You want to switch
to the console?
So I don't think you guys are
really interested in watching
a bunch of Jenkins
scripts, although I
can keep that running.
It's about an hour
and a half long.
So on the console,
as I said earlier,
the first thing we need to
do is connect our networks,
to do the VPC peeering.
So this project is meant to
mimic your own projects on GCP.
This is not the internal
Accenture project
that manages the APC.
So within your project, you're
going to create a VPC network
with a subnet.
You'll have communicated
that to us in the order form.
And we go through the VPC
peering on the left side
and connect our VPC peer that
we've developed-- our VPC
network that we've developed for
your environment to your VPC.
And that allows us, as I
said, to segregate all network
traffic and have
the routes flow.
So then, once that's
done, what you're
able to do is if you go
into the compute in GCE,
when you create a new
server, a VM on GCP,
you're going to select the
network that you build that on.
Go to the compute.
Compute Engine-- there you go.
So I've already built out
a Windows Server just so
that we have a GUI to show you.
But as I said earlier,
when you build that,
you're going to
select the network.
It gets assigned an IP
range within the range
that you've given us.
And then, there's obviously
the public IP to access that.
So if you go to the RDP now
for that Windows Server--
it's already downloaded.
So if we just go to
here, click twice.
No, click twice.
No, here.
MATTHEW ABERNATHY: Did
it come up all right?
Nope.
There it is.
FIRAS GHANTOUS: The password
should still be there.
So this is a Windows
machine in GCP.
You just saw that
earlier on the console.
And if you go to Toad--
we're using Toad
here just to show--
we're going to connect
to the database.
The IP of the database
is 10.200.0.12.
Just going to
enter the password.
Let's hope we got that right.
So now we're in the database.
We're going to just
upload a quick Excel
file into that database
under Import here.
Under Import.
And third one down,
Import Table Data.
And then, yeah, select Under
Tables in the dropdown.
No, no, the one below it, sorry,
the first one, and then you
just have to move it up.
Hit [INAUDIBLE].
Sorry.
MATTHEW ABERNATHY:
No, that's all right.
FIRAS GHANTOUS: So I'm going
to select an Excel file that's
just a simple CSV.
And I'm going to trim
that last column.
It is now uploaded.
This is all the data
that's in there.
And if we go to Database
Sessions with Schema Browser--
MATTHEW ABERNATHY: Data,
right there, second--
FIRAS GHANTOUS: Thank you.
So you can see there that there
is the data that we uploaded.
So this is a functioning
Oracle database
that's running on the
AOPC connected into GCP.
And we said it's
a fast connection.
If we switch to the ping, so
we're pinging that same IP
address 10.200.0.22.
And you can see that--
well, I should
look at the screen.
It is 1 millisecond away.
So this is still going
through the RACK network.
So it goes up to the top of
RACK, goes through a firewall
that we have, through
the segregated VPC,
back into GCP hitting a VM
within should be less than 1
millisecond.
I think ping doesn't
really show that.
But at most, it's 1 millisecond.
So that should enable you to run
most of your application tier
or your web tier in GCP and
still get good performance back
to hit that database.
As I said earlier,
there's no data egress,
so you can suck all that
data into BigQuery, BigTable,
run ML/AI against it, any
of the cool data stuff
that Google has without
data egress costs,
without managing an Oracle
database, getting it out
of your data center
and into GCP.
So I think-- yeah,
back to slides please.
So that's our demo.
Our next slide-- so if
you've got any questions,
obviously you can ask here.
We'll be around.
You can email
agbe-mps@accenture.com.
That'll come to
Dan, Matt, or myself
where we can help you
out with any questions.
You can also go to the
Google Cloud Marketplace.
That'll be live next week,
and start an order form.
That'll also get you
connected with us.
I think, this will be shown
on that-- that contact
information will be
shown on that first page.
One more thing
about the ordering
I forgot to mention earlier,
after you submit the order when
you're ready to
proceed, what'll happen
is we'll send you what's
called private URL pricing.
Again, that just has
to do with our ability
to be able to add
nodes in the future
should you want to do
that, things like that.
So we send you a URL
somebody from the company.
They click on that, and that's
how you execute the order.
So again, it's Dan
who spoke earlier.
My name is Firas.
And that's Matt.
[MUSIC PLAYING]